páginas blancas y Silencio en los
escenarios los 11.500 miembros del
sindicato de guionistas de Estados
Unidos entran en huelga desde este
martes con el voto del 98% de los
miembros del sindicato a favor de la
huelga el comportamiento de las empresas
ha creado una economía de prestación de
servicios dentro de una fuerza de
trabajo sindical y su postura inamovible
en esta negociación ha traicionado un
compromiso para evaluar aún más la
profesión de escritor el sindicato lo
califica de momento existencial la feroz
competencia entre los servicios de
streaming y el auge la producción de
contenidos crean más puestos de trabajo
pero
erosionan las condiciones laborales y
salariales los estudios dicen estar
dispuestos a aumentar la remuneración
pero no pueden aceptar propuestas de
requisitos mínimos de personal la
presión de los inversores para mejorar
la rentabilidad ha hecho que gigantes
del streaming como Disney Plus y Netflix
ya estén intentando frenar el gasto al
conocerse la noticia de la huelga
directores y actores se unieron a los
guionistas en Twitter y en persona en la
Met gala de Nueva York Tienen que llegar
a un acuerdo justo
Necesito a mis guionistas Los necesito
mucho
la última huelga del sindicato de
guionistas comenzó en 2007 y duró 100
días se calcula que costó a la economía
de California unos 2100 millones de
dólares